Not too long ago, anxiety disorders were considered by many to be a personal weakness rather than a true illness, especially in children. Thankfully, this stigma is on the decline, but finding appropriate treatments for children isn't always easy. In this episode, we speak with a psychologist who has been researching the best treatments and assessments for anxiety disorders. She tells us what parents, teachers, and anyone who works with kids needs to know. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychologists. psychologist Golda Ginsburg is a professor of psychiatry at the University of Connecticut Health Center and has been developing treatments for anxious youth for more than 20 years. She led the largest national longitudinal study of anxious youth in the United States to examine the long-term
不久前，焦虑症在许多人眼中还被视为一种个人软弱，而非真正的疾病，尤其是在儿童身上。值得庆幸的是，这种污名化正在减少，但为儿童找到合适的治疗方法并不总是那么容易。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位一直致力于研究焦虑症最佳治疗和评估方法的心理学家。她将告诉家长、老师以及任何与孩子打交道的人需要了解的知识。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学对话》。心理学家戈尔达·金斯伯格是康涅狄格大学健康中心的精神病学教授，她研究焦虑青少年的治疗方法已超过20年。她领导了美国规模最大的焦虑青少年全国纵向研究，以考察焦虑症的长期
outcomes of anxiety treatments and is now following up with a study to examine the long-term effect of family-based treatments for the children of anxious parents. Welcome, Dr. Ginsburg. Hello, nice to be here. I want to start talking about what an anxiety disorder is. How is it defined? I think a lot of people worry when their child is anxious in certain situations, such as starting in a new school, for example, but it might be helpful for them to understand the difference between everyday anxiety and anxiety that is a problem in need of professional help. Can you talk about that? Absolutely. It's a great question and one that I hear from parents all the time because anxiety is an emotion that we all experience.
治疗结果，目前正在进行一项后续研究，以考察家庭治疗对焦虑症家长子女的长期影响。欢迎您，金斯伯格博士。你好，很高兴来到这里。我想先谈谈什么是焦虑症。它是如何定义的？我想很多人在孩子在某些情况下感到焦虑时会很担心，比如刚上新学校，但如果能让他们了解日常焦虑与需要专业帮助的焦虑之间的区别，可能会有所帮助。你能谈谈这一点吗？当然可以。这是一个很好的问题，也是我经常从家长那里听到的问题，因为焦虑是我们每个人都会经历的一种情绪。
and in fact, anxiety can be quite helpful to us. It protects us from dangerous situations. In the school context, it helps us to study when we have a test coming up. So anxiety is something we want to make friends with in a way. But there does come a time when anxiety becomes problematic. The definition, just to go back to your first question, the definition of what an anxiety disorder is, for anyone who wants to look at it,
事实上，焦虑对我们非常有帮助。它能保护我们免受危险情况的伤害。在学校环境中，当我们快要考试时，它能帮助我们学习。所以，焦虑在某种程度上是我们想要与之成为朋友的东西。但焦虑确实有变得棘手的时候。回到你的第一个问题，关于焦虑症的定义，对于任何想要了解它的人来说，
is in the diagnostic and statistical management. that's published by the American Psychiatric Association. And it's essentially a list of symptoms that occur and also impair the functioning of children. So that said, there isn't a blood test that you can get to know whether your child or even an adult has an anxiety disorder. So we look to these symptoms. And again, as I said, because anxiety is something we all experience, we can look to what I'm. I think are three key symptoms to identify the signs. The first set of symptoms are physiological symptoms.
它都在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中，该手册由美国精神医学学会出版。它本质上是一份症状清单，这些症状不仅会发生，还会损害儿童的功能。话虽如此，目前还没有一种血液检查可以让你知道你的孩子甚至成年人是否患有焦虑症。所以我们观察这些症状。再说一次，正如我所说，因为焦虑是我们每个人都会经历的事情，我们可以看看我认为识别这些迹象的三个关键症状。第一组症状是生理症状。
So somatic complaints. What we know is that children and adults too, who struggle with anxiety report headaches and stomach aches where there's no medical cause. So that's one sign that parents can look for as they're trying to sort out, is this anxiety that's problematic or not. The second is that we see these children engage in ways of thinking that if we can get them to articulate what their thoughts are, the themes are full of fear and danger. All the kids are going to laugh at me. I'm going to fail my test. What if my mom or dad dies? So those kinds of thoughts are what we notice. And again, another sign that the child is struggling with anxiety.
也就是躯体主诉。我们知道，受焦虑困扰的儿童和成年人都会报告头痛和胃痛，而这些症状并没有医学原因。所以这是家长在试图弄清楚这是否是棘手的焦虑时可以寻找的一个迹象。第二个迹象是，我们看到这些孩子表现出某种思维方式，如果我们能让他们表达出自己的想法，主题往往充满了恐惧和危险。所有的孩子都会嘲笑我。我会考试不及格。如果我的爸爸妈妈死了怎么办？所以我们注意到的是这类想法。这也是孩子受焦虑困扰的另一个迹象。
The third is in their behavior, and the most common and most problematic behavior is avoidance. So as children struggle with anxiety, they begin to avoid what they're afraid of. So if they're afraid of taking tests, they'll avoid going to school. If they're afraid of something terrible happening to their parents, they'll avoid being away from their parents. They'll sleep with them. So avoidance is a big behavior to look for. So those are the three signs that parents can pay attention to. That said, we might all, if we're, say, afraid of flying, we might worry the plane's going to crash,
第三个迹象体现在他们的行为上，最常见且最棘手的行为是回避。当孩子们受焦虑困扰时，他们开始回避自己害怕的事物。如果他们害怕考试，他们就会逃学。如果他们害怕父母发生可怕的事情，他们就会避免离开父母。他们会和父母一起睡觉。所以回避是一个需要注意的重要行为。这些就是家长可以关注的三个迹象。话虽如此，如果我们害怕飞行，我们可能会担心飞机坠毁，
or we might start to feel butterflies in our stomach as we're going. But it doesn't really impair our functioning. We take the plane anyway. So when we start to see children's lives being impaired by these symptoms, that's when it begins to cross over that line to being. helpful and adaptive to being harmful and something that warrants further evaluation and perhaps treatment. Now, anxiety symptoms aren't always the same in all children, correct? For example, you know, what do we know about how anxiety manifests itself in girls versus boys? You know, what accounts for those differences? Yes. So there are, so if you go to the diagnostic and
或者我们在出发时可能会感到胃里有蝴蝶在飞。但这并不会真正损害我们的功能。我们还是会坐飞机。所以，当我们开始看到孩子的生活受到这些症状的损害时，这就是它开始跨越那条线，从有益和适应性转变为有害，并需要进一步评估甚至治疗的时候了。现在，焦虑症状在所有儿童身上并不总是相同的，对吧？例如，我们对焦虑在女孩和男孩身上表现出的差异了解多少？是什么导致了这些差异？是的，所以如果你去看诊断和
statistical manual, there are several kinds of anxiety disorders, if you will. And really, the differences have to do with what the children are afraid of. And we do see some patterns across development. So younger children will more likely be afraid of separation from their parents, whereas older adolescents or older children and into adolescence will have more social anxiety. And in some ways, this could be a reflection of typical developmental fears that go awry. So as teenagers develop a consciousness about what their peers think about them, typical, a child struggling with anxiety will blow those fears out of proportion to the situation.
统计手册，你会发现有几种焦虑症。事实上，差异与孩子们害怕什么有关。我们确实在发育过程中看到了一些模式。年幼的孩子更有可能害怕与父母分离，而年龄较大的青少年或大孩子进入青春期后会有更多的社交焦虑。在某种程度上，这可能反映了典型的发育恐惧出现了偏差。随着青少年开始意识到同龄人对他们的看法，一个受焦虑困扰的孩子会把这些恐惧夸大到与情况不符的程度。
And then that anxiety begins to impair their functioning. When we look at girls versus boys, once a child has an anxiety disorder, we don't see many differences between boys and girls. Prior, what we call subclinical, we see more girls expressing fears in general than boys. Not sure we know the reasons. Some suggest it's hormonal or biological. Some suggest that it's social in the way that girls are raised. When we look at the relation between femininity, for instance, and anxiety, we know there's a positive.
然后这种焦虑开始损害他们的功能。当我们观察女孩和男孩时，一旦孩子患上焦虑症，我们并没有看到男孩和女孩之间有太多差异。在此之前，也就是我们所说的亚临床阶段，我们看到女孩表达恐惧的情况普遍多于男孩。我不确定我们是否知道原因。有人认为这是荷尔蒙或生物学原因。有人认为这是女孩成长过程中的社会原因。例如，当我们观察女性气质与焦虑之间的关系时，我们知道存在一种正相关。
or correlation. So it's probably a combination of the two. Now, your research focuses on anxiety treatments. As a parent, I imagine it's very difficult to decide what the appropriate treatment for my own child is, but your research suggests there are some best practices overall, using evidence-based treatments such as cognitive behavioral therapy and medications. What is your research found on that? We conducted the largest, what's called a comparative clinical trial.
或者说相关性。所以这可能是两者的结合。现在，你的研究重点是焦虑治疗。作为一名家长，我想决定适合自己孩子的治疗方法非常困难，但你的研究表明，总体上有一些最佳实践，即使用循证治疗方法，如认知行为疗法和药物治疗。你的研究对此有何发现？我们进行了规模最大的所谓比较临床试验。
So comparing different treatments to see which one is the best. And in the largest trial that we did, which is 488 children were involved, and adolescents were involved in this study, we compared certraline, which is an SSRI, a selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor, to cognitive behavioral therapy. To the combination. That's a medication. Yes.
通过比较不同的治疗方法来看看哪一种是最好的。在我们进行的规模最大的试验中，有488名儿童和青少年参与了这项研究，我们将舍曲林（一种选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂，即SSRI）与认知行为疗法进行了比较。以及两者的结合。那是一种药物。是的。
Right. Yeah. To cognitive behavioral therapy, which is a talk therapy, which teaches children's specific skills to how to manage and reduce their anxiety, in which exposure or facing your fear is a key component of that treatment. And the combination of the two, to a pill placebo, so a fake inert pill. And what we found after 12 weeks was that the children who received the combination treatment did the best. So about 80% of those children were what we call responders, meaning that they showed clinically meaningful improvement in their anxiety symptoms
对。是的。与认知行为疗法进行比较，这是一种谈话疗法，教给孩子管理和减轻焦虑的具体技能，其中暴露疗法或面对恐惧是该治疗的关键组成部分。并将两者结合与安慰剂（即一种无效的假药）进行了比较。12周后我们发现，接受联合治疗的儿童效果最好。大约80%的儿童被我们称为“反应者”，这意味着他们的焦虑症状在临床上有显著改善，
and in their functioning. Both cognitive behavioral therapy and medicine alone were more effective than the inert pill, but there was no difference between the two of those monotherapy. So one wasn't better than the other? One was not better than the other. So as a parent struggles with what treatment is best for their child, they have choices. And depending on their own preferences and their child's and the severity of their child's anxiety, they might pick one of those three. I know for some parents giving medication is something they're reluctant to do to their child. But when I'm curious, I think a lot of the issue is they wonder, is my child going to be on this medication forever? You know, is, is an anxiety disorder typically a long-term problem? Can someone
并且他们的功能得到了恢复。认知行为疗法和药物治疗单独使用都比无效的安慰剂更有效，但两者单药治疗之间没有差异。所以没有哪一种比另一种更好？没有哪一种比另一种更好。因此，当家长为哪种治疗方法最适合孩子而苦恼时，他们是有选择的。根据他们自己的偏好、孩子的偏好以及孩子焦虑的严重程度，他们可以选择这三种方法中的一种。我知道对于一些家长来说，给孩子用药是他们不愿做的事情。但我很好奇，我想很多问题在于他们想知道，我的孩子会永远服用这种药物吗？你知道，焦虑症通常是一种长期问题吗？有人
grow out of it, for example, or will they always need to monitor it and seek treatment? So if medication is part of the treatment, you know, is it riskier to give drugs to children than to adults? Yeah. Terrific questions, and I'm not sure we have all the answers. So let me start with, is it risky? We have no long-term data on the impact. or negative consequences of medication for anxiety. We just don't know. We are completing a study right now looking at this, and I know my colleagues at other universities are doing the same thing
能摆脱它吗，或者他们是否总是需要监测并寻求治疗？所以如果药物是治疗的一部分，给儿童用药比给成人用药风险更大吗？是的，非常棒的问题，我不确定我们是否有了所有答案。让我先从“有风险吗”开始说起。我们没有关于焦虑药物影响或负面后果的长期数据。我们只是不知道。我们目前正在完成一项研究来观察这一点，我知道我在其他大学的同事也在做同样的事情，
because it's data that's essential. We don't have it yet. That said, the study that we're completing right now, which actually follows children up to nine to ten years after they were initially enrolled in a treatment study for anxiety. Suggest that a good proportion of these children continue to struggle with anxiety. 30% are chronically ill over time, and we need better treatments for that group. About half of them, half of these children are relapsing.
因为这些数据至关重要。我们还没有得到。话虽如此，我们目前正在完成的研究，实际上是在追踪那些最初参加焦虑治疗研究的儿童，时间长达九到十年。研究表明，这些儿童中有很大一部分人继续受焦虑困扰。30%的人长期患病，我们需要为这一群体提供更好的治疗方法。他们中大约有一半人会复发。
So they get better, but then they get worse, and then they get better, and then they get worse. So we need better ways to monitor and understand why they might get worse over time, but then rebound. And then about 20 to 25 percent get well and stay well. So I think the bottom line is it is a chronic illness. It is also possible that a good proportion get better and stay better, but that we need a better system of monitoring. and like we do in dentistry, for instance, we have annual checkups or my insurance plan lets me go every six months. So I think we need to think about mental health using a different
所以他们好转了，但随后又恶化，然后又好转，然后又恶化。因此，我们需要更好的方法来监测和理解为什么他们会随着时间的推移而恶化，然后又反弹。大约20%到25%的人康复并保持健康。所以我认为底线是这是一种慢性病。也有可能很大一部分人好转并保持健康，但我们需要一个更好的监测系统。就像我们在牙科所做的那样，例如，我们有年度检查，或者我的保险计划允许我每六个月检查一次。所以我认为我们需要用不同的模式来思考心理健康，
model, something akin to what we do for other illnesses, well baby checks or dentistry, so that we can catch children prior to them relapsing. Now, anxiety is the most common psychiatric disorder among young people, even more than ADHD and depression. Do we know why it's so common? Is it more prevalent in more recent generations? If so, why? I'm not sure why it's so common. I think there's certainly a lot to worry about today, but I think there are some studies that show it is more prevalent today. It's hard to tease apart whether that's because the methods and the tools we have to identify children are better, and so we're just doing a better job, or whether actually the prevalence has.
类似于我们对其他疾病所做的事情，比如婴儿健康检查或牙科检查，这样我们就能在孩子复发之前发现问题。现在，焦虑是年轻人中最常见的精神障碍，甚至超过了多动症和抑郁症。我们知道为什么它如此普遍吗？它在最近几代人中更普遍吗？如果是这样，为什么？我不确定为什么它如此普遍。我认为今天确实有很多值得担心的事情，但我认为有一些研究表明它在今天确实更普遍。很难区分这是因为我们识别儿童的方法和工具更好了，所以我们做得更好，还是因为患病率实际上
has been increasing over time. I think it's hard to know. Well, Dr. Ginsburg, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a pleasure. Thank you. It's a pleasure to be here. Thanks for listening. If you would like more information on the topics we discussed or if you would like to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着时间的推移一直在增加。我认为很难知道。好的，金斯伯格博士，非常感谢您加入我们。很高兴能与您交谈。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。感谢收听。如果您想了解更多关于我们讨论的主题的信息，或者如果您想收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《心理学对话》节目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。